[Music]
in this morning Saturday session Chris
Cornell the Seattle native is about to
embark on a tour with his band
Soundgarden with a new studio album in
the works he'll perform their classic
black hole Sun in just a moment over the
years he's kept busy with numerous side
projects including writing songs for
movie soundtracks like his new theme
song from the movie the promise but
first I caught up with Chris Cornell at
the Gibson guitar showroom here in New
York is writing a song for a film
different it's different and sort of
unique to the film pretty much every
time Chris Cornell began writing for
films in 1998 when his song Sunshower
appeared in a seduction scene in Great
Expectations the whole thing that sort
of pivots around the scene is Ethan
Hawke trying to put his hand up Gwyneth
Paltrow's leg that one wasn't one of
those moments like Philadelphia was for
Bruce Springsteen this was just the
Horny scene oh that was good though
[Music]
in 2007 he was commissioned to co-write
the song you know my name for the James
Bond film Casino Royale was it all
intimidating writing for a Bond film a
little bit cuz they're our budgets are
huge you know and I end up with like
this sort of editorial staff in my head
of different voices and whoever is
paying the money from the film company
their voice is one of them yeah that a
good voice or a bad voice it's always a
bad voice it's never that's incredible
that's awesome
every note you writing is perfect for
the film Cornell actually scrapped the
first song he wrote for the new film the
promise but then found inspiration in
its story about the Armenian Genocide an
estimated two and a half million
Armenians Assyrians and Greeks were
killed during it after World War one one
of the few physical things people would
grab and take with them when they were
running for their lives literally and
fleeing from their villages with those
photographs of loved ones
well soon
the experience led Cornell whose wife's
family is Greek to visit a refugee camp
in Athens this month it was pretty
incredible they're real and we need to
do everything we can do not to forget
them and that that drew the line to me
back to the promise that echo of that
this is happening in places right now
this isn't just history
set in a beautiful drama mm-hmm this is
today